I found this from going through the
Barnes & Noble blog from an article
earlier this year by Jenny
Kovac II I hope I'm saying her name
right six why a novels that subvert the
Mean Girl trope I know you're not always
writing about sort of interpersonal
relationships but this could apply to
villains so she just kind of opens the
article with she's a cheerleader she's
out to get your best friend for no
apparent reason
she's the ever-popular Mean Girl all of
the fictional team universe while we
love a good Mean Girl and we could
substitute you know antagonist we also
wonder about her backstory why does she
hate everyone what's going on behind the
scenes so I guess it was saying how you
know even with the Mean Girl you have to
give them some sort of human quality
that that makes you maybe feel some
empathy or gives you some reason for why
the person is where they are absolutely
yeah we always say antagonists are the
same as protagonists they believe that
what they're doing is right usually I
mean sure you could have someone that's
like crazy arch and you know maybe there
is no motivation but for the most part
there's a reason why and every character
should have motivating factors they're
much more interesting that way and
should have their own reasons for doing
things I mean the best most classic
example is Star Wars Darth Vader right
and they studied very classical
archetypes when they were putting those
movies together but so Darth Vader is a
hugely frightening scary domineering
antagonist but we do find out his
backstory we do learn that no spoilers
but it was Luke and Leia's father and
that he had his own journey in art and
there's three films that address that so
and as much as people criticize them
what I love about episodes 1 2 & 3 is
that they do give you more insight into
his character so then when you watch the
originals you understand him more and
you're starting to see more where a
character where authors are flipping and
films and looking at the antagonist
Disney's Maleficent did that where they
looked at Maleficent did a whole movie
from her point of view and there have
been quite a few books that have done
the same thing wicked again looks at the
Wicked Witch of the West East I can't
remember but it's um you know Wizard of
Oz but it's retelling the story from her
point of view the witch so I think
that's a really interesting exercise
to think about and I think when you're
developing out characters it's always
good to look at what are their
motivations what are the things that
have shaped them in their lives in my
story the religious contingent that runs
my underwater colony the 13th continuum
they believe that what they're doing is
right they believe that it's saving
their colony they have you know that
their religious beliefs are important
you know even if they're destroying the
world that they live in but they believe
in what they're doing and I think that's
really important
you